the cinematographer brings into focus
sometimes sharp sometimes subtle and
soft images images that live in the
minds of moviegoers images that become
as real and as personal as the memories
and our family album to this day I can
close my eyes and still feel the vivid
portraits and see American in Paris and
American in Paris and Lawrence of La
Arabia feel the Russian winner of Doctor
Zhivago and the sunny warmth of Gigi the
cinematographer is a man for all seasons
and this is their moment and to present
the Award for Best Cinematography are
two people who make the cinematographers
work interesting easier and more
pleasant mrs. Leigh Tyson and Peter
Lawford
the nominees for best achievement in
cinematography are Sven Nykvist for
cries and whispers Owen Roseman for The
Exorcist
Jack Kufa for Jonathan Livingston
Seagull Robert Surtees for the sting
Harry straddling jr. for the way we were
may have the envelope please
the winner is spin
thank you very very very much I'm very
very proud and I am quite sure that this
fine award will give the possibility for
me to make much better work than I've
done before thank you very much
you